la la maison Cola euh vous disiez vous
allez fêter vos 50 ans en septembre
prochain en septembre prochain est en
train de se creuser la tête pour savoir
comment fêter ça dignement parce que on
avait déjà fêté les 40
ans en faisant toute une rétrospective
sur l'année de tous les produits phares
de chaque année c'està-dire qu'on avait
fait des petites stelles dans la
boutique et à chaque fête à l'automne à
Noël à la Valentin à P on avait réédité
les produits phares de chaque année donc
là c'était intéressant puis c'était un
travail un petit peu d'archive et puis
on av on a toujours les premiers
chocolatiers les les deux premiers
apprentis de papa qui sont avec nous ah
oui donc qui ont la mémoire des prod
connaissent tout ce qui s'est passé mais
donc on avait pu faire ça donc là pour
les 50 ans il va falloir trouver une
autre idée on ira tous en septembre à
moule hein voir pour voir que pour voir
qu quelle idée vous avez eu alors vous
êtes vous êtes êtes venu avec un un
trésor oui hein un coffre à trésor
coffre voilà euh ça c'est c'est le c'est
ce que vous proposez pour les pour les
fêtes alors c cette année les c'est ce
sont les chocolatiers qui avait très
envie de faire un thème sur les pirates
et puis donc on on fait filer ce thème
sur toute l'année à la rentrée nous
avons travaillé sur retour des Caraïbes
le chocolat qui vient des Caraïbes bien
sûr donc les chocolats d'Amérique
centrale qui sont les chocolats les plus
renommés les plus aromatiques fruités
acidulé florau aux arômes et puis
ensuite donc les on a fait les pirates
pour Halloween et là pour Noël les
pirates ont trouvé le trésor et donc
nous avons réalisé des des pierres
précieuses en chocolat
tout des pierres délicieuses oui c'est
des pierres précieuses et délicieuses
oui voilà donc nous avons des c'est du
chocolat alors ça c'est de la pâte de
fruits de la ferme du logie à jumoville
d'accord euh on a des pralinés sarrasin
des des pâtes de
d'amande de des pralinées amandes pâtes
de d'orange voilà toute une dégustation
S trèson qui a pris la forme de cristau
c'est magnifique alors là c'est la
collection pour cette fin d'année on
renouvelle nos produits tous les de TR
mois nous en fait quand comme on est
existe depuis 50 ans que notre clientèle
c'est 20 km à la ronde ça n ça nous
oblige à beaucoup renouveler nos nos nos
propositions parce que faut pas lasser
les clients alors on propose toujours
évidemment les petits chocolats
traditionnels on a
gardé la collection une boite no petits
chocolat pour
certains ce sont des chocolats que papa
faisait déjà au tout début d'accord on a
les trois petites noisette caramélisé là
qui sont vraiment produits
phare ça vous tente allez on y va merci
merci
beaucoup petites noisettes caramélisé en
Robé de
chocolat noisette piément
et ça vous dit
oui
Jeon moi je parle alors et et
donc no petit chocolat traditionnel et
moi ce que j'ai apporté dans
l'entreprise c'est en fait le le travail
visuel puisque j'ai une formation
initiale en design on a rappliqué ah
voilà donc j'ai travaillé d'abord un
petit peu dans design avec mon mari et
ensuite quand mes parents envisageai de
prendre leur retraite ça pas été
possible je suis revenue au berkaille
vite fait bien
fait mais c'est formidable qu' soit
resté dans la famille quoi et j'ai
appliqué bah ce que j'avais appris au
chocolat c'est-à-dire la création de
moule la création
la longue vue la longue vue du
pirate je peux sortir ça on peut tout
sortir voilà la bouteille à la
mer donc avec une illustration qui est
réalisée tout au pinceau avec des
pigments alimentaires et beurre de cacao
donc là c'est un travail de peintre ben
dans l'équipe j'ai une jeune femme qui a
un DMA de d'art plastique qui se
demander un peu comment elle allait
gagner sa vie avec cette formation et
une amie commune nous a présenté et elle
est spécialiste de la peinture sur
chocolat c'est magnifique hein c'est vra
faut la coucher comme ça là faut la
coucher voilà le bateau oui le bateau
comm ça
voilà c'estuss c'est sublime donc euh
voilà c'est ce c'est c'est c'est notre
touche c'est notre pâte par rapport à à
la formation les
chocolatiers c'est c'est pas le type
d'esthétique que l'on apprend en école
de chocolaterie donc ça ça nous ça nous
permet d'avoir une identitéelle
différente absolument ou ou avoir notre
identité c'estd que c'est c'est à la
fois voilà vous vous conciliez le le le
la qualité du produit parce que c'est je
viens de goûter là c'est magnifique
quand même hein avec avec oui le design
avec la présentation
avec oui c'est c'est de l'art quoi on
s'amuse avec la
matière le chocolat c'est vraiment un
produit qui est agréable à travailler
qui se met en forme qui au niveau des
goûts permet beaucoup d'associations
beaucoup de fantaisie beaucoup de
une palette aromatique aussi très très
large donc c'est vraiment une matière
avec laquellequ pe on peut vraiment se
faire plir décler
s'us évidemment votre votre maison mais
c'est vrai qu'on a on a de on est un
pays de grand chocolatier hein oui euh
les les choc c'est en France qu'on
déguste les chocolats les plus typés les
moins sucrés oui vous avez beaucoup de
confrères France d'ailleurs dans les
dans les chocolat ou c'est vrai que
c'est on est on est très bon quoi mais
en fait on a le un peu le palais du vin
justement du fromage et ce qui qui aussi
permet de déguster les chocolats de
façon assez subtile c'est subtile